un todoterreno volcado y destrozado ya
se inmóvil justo al lado de esta
carretera de los ángeles
esa fue la escena donde pocas horas
antes la leyenda del golf tiger woods
perdió el control de su vehículo y se
estrelló el martes por un breve momento
el mundo del golf esperó con la
respiración contenida preocupado por que
boots pudiera estar gravemente herido o
algo peor
quiero decir es algo que me revuelve el
estómago ya sabes me duele ver a uno de
mis mejores amigos teniendo un accidente
espero que esté bien
pero cuando el ayudante del sheriff
asomó la cabeza por el parabrisas y le
preguntó su nombre se escuchó una lúcida
respuesta tiger había escapado a lo peor
directa es muy afortunado que el señor
woods había podido salir vivo de esto
tenía la naturaleza de su vehículo el
hecho de que llevaba el cinturón de
seguridad
diría que aumentó en gran medida la
probabilidad de que le salvara la vida
la gravedad del impacto fue sin embargo
inmediatamente evidente el ganador de
quince meier se había lesionado
gravemente ambas piernas y fue llevado a
cirugía
llegando con fracturas expuestas en
tibia y peroné-
las reacciones se sucedieron con
personajes como michael tyson jack
nicklaus y el expresidente donald trump
deseando una pronta recuperación al
hombre considerado el mejor golfista de
la historia la pregunta obvia para los
aficionados es si woods podrá volver a
jugar golf